all right Kyle Bravo con is underway is
it everything you expected it to be or
more it's way less chaotic like it's
very organized and I thought it was just
gonna be like a zoo but it's not it's
been great fun to see people that you
know I don't get to see that often in
the other cities and it's just fun
you're in the middle of filming the next
season there are lots of rumors reports
out there that nothing is happening set
the record straight for me something
else that's definitely not what's the
case is absolutely not you'll be nice
though because if you a lot more
relaxing wouldn't be no you know what we
have you know a lot of stuff going on
obviously with all these women and two
new cast members and like usual not
everyone gets along everyone has a
different opinion about things so you
know it's not just only drama we also do
have fun too and you know great trips
and exciting stuff going on so it's a
little mix of everything but never a
dull moment in Beverly Hills no and you
got two new women who I think are mixing
up the mix right now yeah exactly they
are down Lisa Vanderpump who is
somewhere around these parts right now
yes if you have to see her tonight talk
to her tonight how is that going to go I
would say hi how are you I just bumped
into her in Beverly Hills uh about a
week and a half ago and I said how are
you so it's cordial I mean it is on my
end do you would you ever want to see
her come back to the show or do you like
the show without her in the mix I always
am like nostalgic you know when people
ways ask you know the original cast from
season one like of course I'd love to
have any of them back
we've seen you make some cameos on
Keeping Up with the Kardashians what
would it take your films it yes exactly
skin was for Kim's shapewear what will
it take to get Chris to come to a
housewife's cameo oh well just stay
tuned okay could it maybe be at that a
party where we also got Brandi to come
Kim to come Eileen to come to tune in
this season and see for yourself
[Music]